[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 ledo l'émission de
la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 8
décembre
4e journée de grève dans les cantines
yvelinoise les agents des services de
restauration et nettoyage des
établissements scolaires sont contre la
volonté du département d'introduire un
partenaire privé pour la gestion des
cantines les deux parties s'opposent
notamment sur les conséquences pour la
qualité est des produits
le directeur général de l'afm téléthon
qui son côté notre invité fil rouge pour
cette émission nous évoquons avec lui la
31e édition du téléthon prévu tout le
week end et les enjeux pour la recherche
sur les maladies rares
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
retour évidemment sur la disparition de
deux jeunes yal'idée avec la rencontre
touchante d'une fana voisins le
bretonneux ou encore les policiers
municipaux désormais équipés de caméras
cetto s'est presque donc devenu une
habitude tous les jeudis depuis un mois
les agents des services restauration et
nettoyage des collèges du département
des yvelines sont en grève ils
protestent contre la réforme souhaitée
par le conseil départemental de
transférer l la gestion de cette
activité à une société d'économie mixte
ce qui impliquerait la mise en place
d'un partenaire privé elle les
explications et les détails avec nicolas
d'andré un front syndical opposé à la
création d'une société d'économie mixte
pour la gestion de la restauration et du
nettoyage dans les collèges syndicats du
département du personnel de l'éducation
nationale et des parents d'élèves
tous sont mobilisés contre ce projet du
conseil départemental
ils s'inquiètent à propos des conditions
de travail de la qualité du service
le département fait le choix de faire de
réduire l'investissement au niveau des
collèges puisqu'un des objectifs c'est
de maîtriser les coûts et de réduire la
dépense mais dans le même temps il le
confier au privé ce qui veut dire qu'une
partie de l'argent investi de l'argent
public investi va partir en dividendes
pour des actionnaires
tant de là ça veut dire qu'il y aura
moins d'argent pour la qualité des
produits moins d'argent pour la masse
salariale donc forcément il y aura un
impact négatif pour le personnel et pour
les les services rendus aux collégiens
près de 800 agents sont concernés dans
les 110 collèges du département
actuellement plusieurs modes de gestion
sont en place dans les cantines 56% sont
directement gérés par la collectivité
44% par des entreprises privées
la société d'économie mixte permettrait
d'harmoniser la gestion avec un contrôle
de la collectivité veut faciliter
l'accès à la restauration passait
tarification sociale en mettant un petit
peu de d'équité et donner le goût des
aliments redonneront relancer un petit
peu l'agriculture locale lutter contre
le gaspillage alimentaire des objectifs
qui pourrait être inscrit dans le cahier
des charges dans le cadre d'un appel
d'offres sa rédaction est prévue pour
février 2018
d'ici là une délibération doit être
votée le 22 décembre lors de la
prochaine assemblée départementale
en marge de la séance les syndicats ont
prévu de manifester devant l'hôtel du
département en politique et en bref le
conseil constitutionnel rejette ce
vendredi la requête de jean michel
fourgous le maire d'elancourt avait
saisi l'institution mois de juin pour
annuler l élection de nadia et sur la
11e circonscription des yvelines le
candidat des républicains d'alors
dénoncer notamment plusieurs abus de
propagande
un argument avec d'autres que la cour
constitutionnelle n'a donc pas retenu
pour rappel nadia et de la république en
marche a été élu avec près de 53% des
suffrages exprimés le 18 juin dernier
deux cent mille bénévoles mobilisés cinq
millions de français participant est
aussi à des millions de téléspectateurs
devant leur écran elle la 31e édition du
téléthon se tient tout le week end les
années passent mais les enjeux restent
elles mêmes récolter des fonds pour
soutenir la recherche sur les maladies
rares et soutenir aussi les malades eux
mêmes
pour en parler nous sommes en plateau
avec christian côté bonsoir aux foires
vous êtes le directeur général de l'afm
téléthon
première question peut être un peu
triste j'ai envie de dire mais est ce
que le directeur général du téléthon de
l'afm téléthon
craint-il que l'actualité est l'hommage
rendu samedi à johnny hallyday entraîne
une mobilisation en baisse des français
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
prenez en compte
ou alors on fait confiance bien sûr que
des ce qu'on a pris en compte
johnny hallyday nous l'avons vu
régulièrement dans le thé les tories qui
étaient invités ayant absolument donc
quelque part si cette année zazie à la
barrette du téléthon on peut on peut
dire que johnny est le parrain de coeur
du téléthon est bien évidemment cette
cérémonie qui va se dérouler sur les
champs-elysées à l'église de la
madeleine
eh bien nous y associons également nous
avons ajusté avec france télévisions
l'organisation ait le déroulé de
l'émission de façon à ce que ils
puissent pas il n'y ait pas de
concurrence entre nous pour suivre
quoi qu'il arrive tous les toutes les
heures de direct sur france télévisions
alors il y aura une bascule ils
n'assurent selon les différentes chaînes
de france télévisions et notamment un
peu à l'image de ce qui se passe ou 2 et
france 3 sur le tour de france est
absolument
petite question l'an passé vous aviez
récolté 93 millions d'euros à peu près
je crois à 92 millions d'euros sept cent
mille euros
à quel moment vous dites que la collecte
n'est pas satisfaisante à quel moment
vous dit que c'est une collecte
exceptionnelle alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que plus on avance dans le
développement des thérapeutiques plus
les programmes coûte cher d'accord dont
nous avons besoin de cet argent puisque
on peut dire que si landais premier
téléthon
nous avons surtout travaillé en
soutenant la recherche fondamentale
nous avons travaillé à l'identification
des gènes dont les mutations sont
responsables des maladies notamment avec
notre laboratoire généthon
progressivement nous sommes passés au
développement des thérapeutiques aux
essais cliniques rd612
et fier que ça dure et très fier parce
que quand on est dans la recherche
fondamentale pour comprendre chacun des
programmes
outre quelques dizaines à quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros quand on
est au stade des applications sur
l'homme c'est en millions et en dizaines
de millions d'euros qu'il faut chiffrer
et aujourd'hui nous soutenons et nous
avons en cours ou en préparation
trente trois essais sur l'homme ça
concerne 26 maladie c'est dire si les
besoins financiers sont importants donc
est attendue sans nous donner de chiffre
particulier vous confère aussi bien
qu'il faut être bien rester mobilisés
c'est ce qu'on comprend et pourrait pour
comprendre l'ampleur de votre tâche
peut-être quelques chiffres notamment
sur sur les maladies rares aujourd'hui
on en dénombre entre six et huit mille
en france qui concerne 3 millions de
français quand on parle de mal à dire
arar le terme peut peut-être faire peur
comme ça avec de quoi parle-t-on alors
en fait on parle de baladi qui concerne
très peu de personnes pour chacune des
maladies mais comme elles sont très
nombreuses
mis bout à bout ça représente le chiffre
avait indiqué c'est à dire 3 millions de
français 30 millions d'européens qui
sont concernés par l'une ou l'autre de
ces maladies rares
ces maladies peuvent toucher toutes les
fonctions vitales
tous les organes c'est à dire qu'il ya
des maladies des muscles bien sûr mais
aussi du sang du cerveau du système du
système nerveux central du foie etc
il n'y a pas de limites et les travaux
que nous soutenons sont très diversifiés
à travers ces différentes de ces
maladies mais en même temps ils ont
aussi des retombées positives en termes
de connaissance est applications
thérapeutiques potentielles sur les
maladies fréquentes
alors on le disait 3 millions de
français 30 millions d'européens
concrètement ça peut peut-être motivé
certains à faire un don quand on fait un
don en fait on fait forcément un don
pour quelqu'un on connaît forcément
quelqu'un qui est concerné presque par
une maladie rare ou en tout cas on
présume 3 millions de français on a
forcément dans son entourage un ami une
connaissance qui est concerné par les
maladies rares 1 un français sur bas
puisque en fait ce qui définit une
maladie rare c'est lorsque vous prenez
une population moins de une personne sur
2000 donc ça veut dire que
statistiquement c'est un français sur 20
qui est concerné mais il faut savoir
qu'à des maladies qui peuvent concerner
quelques dizaines de milliers de malades
en france mais beaucoup de ces maladies
sont très rares elles vont concerner
quelques centaines quelques dizaines
voire quelques patients et ceci explique
pourquoi historiquement ni la science ni
la médecine ne s'est intéressé à ces
pathologies et grâce au téléthon grâce à
l'impulsion donnée grâce vous faites la
générosité des français il faut
rattraper ce retard
pour ces maladies qui sont souvent très
lourdes souvent mortels et qui frappe
pour la moitié d'entre elles les enfants
d'ailleurs avec le temps l'afm téléthon
s'est développé vous avez créer vos
propres laboratoires c'est à dire que
tous les noms par exemple 93 millions
d'euros l'an passé
tous les dons vous mon sur ces
laboratoires ils sont consacrer
entièrement à ses laboratoires
uniquement nous allons en effet
développé de nos laboratoires et les
taux pour la thérapie génique maladies
rares i stay pour la thérapie cellulaire
l'institut de biologie mais nous
finançons aussi beaucoup de programmes
de recherche avec des partenaires des
universités les grands hôpitaux
parisiens
les instituts de recherche en france par
exemple in faire ou à l'étranger mais
également une partie de cet argent sert
à l'aide et au soutien aux malades et
aux familles dans leur vie quotidienne
est ce qu'il ya des avancées concrètes
je crois savoir qu'en 2018 vous allez
vous avez vous allez lancer des
recherches en tout cas des essais pour
des maladies qui concerne la rétine
c'est une avancée concrète a fêté ça
fait plusieurs années que nous
travaillons sur les maladies rares de la
rétine
aujourd'hui des médicaments sont près
d'être mise à disposition des ballades
mais nous continuerons tant en termes de
tarab de thérapie cellulaire que en
termes de thérapie génique c'est à ce
moment là qu'il faut pas lâcher
maintenant lâcher d'autant plus que nous
avons faire un pas de plus en 2016 c'est
que les essais cliniques servent à
démontrer l'efficacité de ces
traitements innovants mais il faut aussi
les produire pour les mettre à
disposition
l avons créé une plateforme industrielle
de production de médicaments de thérapie
génique et cellulaire qui va permettre
de produire ces médicaments en quantité
pour les malades qui en ont tellement
besoin
un mot peut-être on parle souvent de la
recherche et c'est normal c'est ça
l'enjeu principal mais la recherche
c'est pour le futur mais l'afm téléthon
c'est aussi un accompagnement social
c'est peut-être l'achat de matériel
c'est pour aussi le court terme c'est
pas uniquement la recherche il faut pas
oublier ça aussi celle des jeux là avec
une chaise roulante ou à l'effet dès le
début l'ont bien compris que la question
de l'art de guérir de la mise au point
des traitements c'est une affaire de
très long terme c'est une affaire de
génération
nous allons faire nous sommes en train
de lancer le 31e téléthon mais nous
sommes aux portes des thérapeutiques
pour autant il faut aider les malades et
les familles aujourd'hui maintenant dans
leur vie quotidienne
ça veut dire les accompagner pour qu'ils
puissent accéder à des soins de qualité
faire de la prévention les aider à
bénéficier de tous les soutiens que les
pouvoirs publics ont mises en place ne
pas se substituer à la puissance
publique c'est à dire que vous parliez
de financer des outils d aide technique
de compensation les systèmes de
financement existe par contre lorsqu'il
ya des restes à charge qui sont parfois
importants vous pouvez les uns
techniques sophistiquées là dedans le
petit coup de pouce financier pour aider
la famille à disposer le plus rapidement
possible de l'aide technique dont elle a
besoin
la mobilisation est donc vital pour
soutenir les malades comme tous les ans
de nombreuses communes saint quentin en
yvelines seront mobilisés tout le
week-end et ce grâce aux associations et
bénévoles sur le terrain tour d'horizon
des manifestations prévues jusqu'à
dimanche avec ce reportage
cinq millions de français tous les ans
et des milliers d'yves linois la 31e
édition du téléthon sera une nouvelle
fois un rendez vous important pour la
solidarité et la recherche contre les
maladies rares à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de nombreux
acteurs locaux sont mobilisés c'est le
cas des chocs ce des longs cours qui
organiseront dimanche leur
traditionnelle disco roller entre 14 et
18 heures traditionnel aussi les
animations prévues vendredi et samedi au
centre sportif les pyramides de
voisins-le-bretonneux ou encore les 25
heures d'activités non stop organisé par
l'association objectif téléthon manie
quoi elle l'édition 2016 avait permis de
récolter près de 700000 euros sur les
yvelines un gain est essentielle pour
soutenir la recherche en avance
ce avant ce tous les ans là mais il ya
encore beaucoup à faire sur l'est les
problèmes de vue sur les problèmes des
des muscles tout ça en un respiratoires
aussi en a encore beaucoup à faire au
niveau de la recherche
malheureusement le tunnel est encore
lent manifestation historique aussi sur
saint quentin en yvelines les trois
jours d'événements au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin dès vendredi soir à
montigny le bretonneux où les 30 heures
d'animations aux clayes-sous-bois avec
un fest noz samedi soir pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer il est toujours
possible de faire un don par téléphone
ou sur internet
l'an dernier 80 millions d'euros ont été
récoltés par tout en france lors du
téléthon et on précise que évidemment 80
millions d'euros c'était les promesses
finalement le téléthon a récolté 93
millions d'euros je voulais vous vous
posez peut-être une des questions déjà
sur la mobilisation on sait que le
département des yvelines est très
mobilisé il ya beaucoup d'événements qui
sont qui sont organisées globalement en
france ya énormément de bénévoles qui
sont mobilisés peut-être un mot pour eux
aussi souligner leur travail j'imagine
que tous les ans ça doit vous vous
toucher cette générosité ces gens qui
sont là juste pour la bonne cause
alors c'est un élan extraordinaire avait
fait les yvelines sont très mobilisés
puisque c'est pas moins de deux cent
mille deux cents perdant 2 210
animations qui vont avoir lieu durant ce
téléthon sur sur le territoire d
l'ide donc très grande utilisation des
bénévoles des associations des clubs des
partenaires des fanfares des orchestres
des écoles etc etc
il faut aussi souligner leur
mobilisation est importante quand trois
mille partenaires associatifs ou
fédérations sportives parlant qui sont
mobilisés chaque année est donc grand
coup de chapeau à ces bénévoles qui sont
quelque part l'adn du téléthon et qui
permettent ce grand mouvement de
générosité publique
donc le 36 37 kg et ouvert après après
le 9 décembre
alors elle qui est déjà ouvert à l'est
des journaux qui a ouvert ce matin et
qui va rester ouvert toute la semaine
qui va suivre le téléthon quant au
téléthon préfère il va rester ouvert
pendant le mois pendant le mois de
décembre
voilà donc pour faire un don vous pouvez
appeler via téléphone le 36 37 aussi via
internet vous voyez sa fiche et les
informations en bas de votre écran afm
tirer être telethon.fr pour faire un don
merci christian côté d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur général de l'afm téléthon
merci à vous et puis aussi bon week end
bon courage mais j'aspire à être animés
et merci aux donateurs des yvelines qui
sont très nombreuses on passe maintenant
à l'actualité de la semaine
l'actualité de cette semaine marque est
évidemment par la disparition mercredi
de johnny hallyday la star du rock
français est décédé mercredi à l'âge de
74 ans des suites d'un cancer des
poumons une actualité qui ne cesse
évidemment de faire la une de la presse
française depuis quelques jours et qui a
fait réagir beaucoup de personnes
politiques acteurs aussi du monde
culturel ou encore de simples citoyens
comme à saint quentin en yvelines
regardez quelle image je vais garder de
johnny ben je pense qu'il a marqué la
chanson française un bon chanteur qui
nous accompagnent et pratiquement une
autre âge tout le monde notre d'autres
devis quoi on l'a découvert au monde et
est tout jeune toute hâte au une très
très bonne image de lui
on se rappellera de tous ses titres de
chansons telles que l'oral pénitencier
noir c'est noir
c'est un grand moment un grand homme tu
t'y samba chez quelqu'un quand même
exceptionnel
je crois que tout tout tout le monde
regrettera c'est ce personnage qui
étaient hors normes
bah ça va faire trois quatre générations
qui vont être atteindre c'est plutôt
rare j'ai 51 ans il avait nié mon enfant
je qualifie ce que je sais de lui chez
moi mais malgré tout ce qu'on aime ou de
chez soi sans ça a bercé notre jeunesse
c'est le premier sûr que j'ai fait mon
mari si sûr johnny hallyday
malheureusement notre génération garde
une image de lui un peu dans l'agonie à
toujours faire des fêtes news sur les
skis murray ce qu'il meure pas c'est un
phénomène c'est comme c'est un peu comme
à michael jackson on a l'impression que
c'est des stars qui sont limite immortel
donc c'est un peu triste je les connais
depuis tout petit en gros va il fait
partie de l'histoire au même titre que
jean d'ormesson sur des grands qui vient
de nous quitter
et cette nouvelle a évidemment
bouleversé principalement les plus
grands fans de johnny hallyday à voisins
le bretonneux la rédaction de tv 78 a pu
recueillir les premières réactions de
liliane cette passionnée de johnny a
même suivi sa star lors d'un concert à
las vegas reportage de camille lambert
[Musique]
paradis comme beaucoup aujourd'hui
liane a perdu son idole ses souvenirs
c'est justement ce qui lui restera de
celui qui l'a accompagné depuis ses 13
ans j'avais une amie qui avait deux ans
de plus que moi donc c'était la grande
voile à petit puis un jour elle me dit
il ya johnny hallyday qui sort à 1,10 et
nous la partie acheter ce fameux disque
qui est sorti en mars 1960
j'ai pratiquement tous ses disques
toujours tous les albums mais en fin de
contrat de la peine on a de la peine et
puis alors comme tu écoutes les
témoignages de tout le monde est obligé
d'avoir une grande peine s'est il fait
partie de ma vie depuis l'âge que j'ai
13 ans et j'en ai eu que 70 à une vie
rythmée par les sorties d'albums et les
concerts fans dévoués liliane a suivi
son johnny partout même à l'autre bout
de l'atlantique
miami celle de death de gasques en 1991
[Musique]
merveilleux vegas mes parents me faire
ça pour mes 50 ans est un vrai beau le
départ à l'aéroport des petits génies
partout des dans l'avion dans l'avion
tout ce qu'on a eues mais je pourrais le
parti mille fois à las vegas je n'aurais
jamais un voyage comme ça et on est des
femmes c'était formidable pour se
rappeler ces bons moments des objets à
l'effigié de son icône des dédicaces et
des photos pour l'entourer dernière
acquisition en date de son club
les calendriers 2018 malheureusement que
johnny ne verra pas le calendrier du fan
club de nîmes et access ayant nahd
voilà ils en ont fait d'eux une
collection qui continuera de s'agrandir
malgré la perte et la tristesse ne
restera que les saisies
mais resteront sur scène ou reste toutes
ses chansons
[Musique]
un peu plus de 5 milliards d'euros
valérie pécresse a présenté mercredi le
budget 2010 8 de la région ile-de-france
un budget marqué notamment par 700
millions d'euros d'investissements pour
les transports en commun les précisions
avec ce reportage
des investissements hausse des dépenses
de fonctionnement en baisse
la recette budgétaire de valérie
pécresse reste inchangé pour 2018
la région ile-de-france fixe notamment
comme objectif principal de devenir la
première métropole écologique d'europe
pour y parvenir plus de 700 millions
d'euros seront consacrés aux
investissements dans les transports avec
la poursuite de la modernisation du
réseau ferroviaire dans le sport la
culture ou encore la ruralité la région
dépenserait également l'an prochain près
de 300 millions d'euros pour tenter de
réduire les fractures territoriales et
sociales entre paris et la banlieue
nous sommes aussi désormais très engagée
dans le développement de la ruralité et
dans le maintien en banlieue de tout ce
qui fait l'attractivité des villes de
banlieue
en clair ce que nous voulons c'est que
l'on puisse trouver du travail
près de chez soi vivre en banlieue et
que toute la richesse toute la culture
tout le sport toute l'attractivité ne
soient pas captés par par paris en
charge des lycées la région consacrera
également aux établissements 780
millions d'euros
la formation professionnelle et
l'apprentissage se voient eux dotés
d'une enveloppe de 570 millions d'euros
enfin le déménagement du siège de la
région en banlieue et la réduction des
effectifs permettront d'économiser près
de 40 millions d'euros dans les rangs de
l'opposition les critiques sont
nombreuses pour juger ce troisième
budget de l'ère valérie pécresse
le groupe socialiste évoque notamment
une politique son ambition pour les
franciliens
le vote du budget par les élus est prévu
entre le 18 et le 20 décembre prochain
un équipement supplémentaire pour la
police municipale des longs cours après
armée excusez moi depuis mai dernier les
agents disposent désormais de caméras
piétons cinq appareils ont été remis
lundi par le maire de la ville jean
michel fourgous coût total de
l'équipement 3500 euros aides et
dispositifs porter au niveau du torse ou
de l'épaule déclenchée aux besoins des
policiers qui peuvent enregistrer
l'image et le son lors des interventions
et qui sont également mises à
disposition de la justice en cas de
litige
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude c'est un vrai plus pour la
sécurité aussi bien des agents
on va le faire différemment et c'est
plus pour la sécurité des victimes des
mises en cause et des agents il ya des
noms d'oiseaux qui sont échangées et
pour eux souvent de la parole des agents
que ce soit de la police nationale
gendarmerie police municipale soit remis
en cause lors des enquêtes de procédures
annexes et dont paul c'est c'est une
sécurité une garantie aussi que pour les
agents de police à noter que ces caméras
sont en phase de tests jusqu'en juin
prochain les policiers municipaux de
montigny le bretonneux sont également
équipés du même dispositif
c'est une expression de plus en plus
répandue dans le monde médical les
déserts médicaux justement ces
territoires où le manque de médecins se
fait ressentir chaque année à saint
quentin en yvelines et la ville de
plaisir justement souhaitait être
reconnu comme zones de fragilité par l'
agence régionale de santé et met
également en place à un plan d'action
pour tenter d'inverser la tendance
camille lambert
ils étaient 24 dans les années 90 ils ne
sont plus que onze aujourd'hui à plaisir
comme dans beaucoup d'autres villes
on manque de médecins un constat établi
par les premiers intéressés avec la
commune et madame le maire qui m'a
invité pour présenter pour montrer
pourquoi les médecins ne voulais pas
faire ça l'est pourquoi on avait du mal
à retrouver des médecins les médecins
préfèrent avoir plus de repos et moins
travaillé depuis les 35 heures on
n'avait pas les conditions de travail
alors à un cliché qui aurait fait social
1h02
de travail pour faire des papiers qui
sert pratiquement à rien on fait les
doubler après quatre ans de recherche
cet ancien médecin n'a trouvé aucun
repreneur à la suite de son départ à la
retraite
la commune de plaisir souhaitent se
mobiliser en faveur d'un retour des
médecins sur son territoire la ville
travaille actuellement à la création
d'une maison de santé pluridisciplinaire
qui serait complètement prise en charge
au niveau de l'investissement par les
départements et qui accompagnerait
pendant trois ans au niveau du
fonctionnement avec les secrétaires
médicales donc on va déjà expliquer tout
ça aux médecins et aux pharmaciens en
sachant que nous avons aussi une maison
médicale privée qui va ouvrir un côté je
dirais d'un du centre commercial de
façon à ce que là aussi il y ait une
série de médecins qui arrivent et
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit il y aurait
deux médecins généralistes war 3 qui
viendrait dans cette maison médicale
privée un plan d'action mis en place
avec les pharmaciens les médecins et
saint quentin en yvelines
un engagement que la commune soit de
faire connaître aux habitants une
campagne d'information sera lancée début
2010 8
une idée de sortie pour terminer cette
émission et pour votre week end
également jusqu'à dimanche se tient au
château de plaisir le 8e salon à des
arts 18 exposants présentent trois
oeuvres chacun de la peinture et de la
sculpture reportage de mélanie poquet
arnaud ces banques répondent donner de
nouvelles lectures de la matière
pervertir nos sensations cet artiste
plasticien travail les métaux depuis 15
ans
il est l'invité d'honneur de ce 8e salon
des heures de plaisir
l'originalité la qualité de son travail
la légèreté il le dit lui même il traite
la matière je dirais pour nous
surprendre et pour nous que faire
déclencher des émotions
effectivement c'est tout à fait ça il ya
une espèce de subtilité de douceur dans
ses oeuvres qui je pense vont pas
laisser insensible au public pour cette
nouvelle édition 18 artistes ont répondu
présent
de la sculpture de la peinture cette
année une majorité des oeuvres fait la
part belle à l'art abstrait on n'a pas
donné tu aimes mes ans il est clair que
vous savez l'art c'est quelque chose qui
entraîne des sensations qui entraîne des
images et donc je crois que la
commission qui met ça en place bon de
réagir en fonction de ses émotions
je crois que c'est pour ça que ça va
peut-être vers l'abstrait plus cette
année ce sera peut-être plus figuratifs
l'année prochaine il faut se laisser
porter c'est important
une exposition le public est amené à
voter pour son oeuvre préférée
remise des prix le dimanche 10 décembre
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information en direct lundi à 18
heures d'ici là restez informés et
connecté grâce à notre site internet et
notre application tv 78 bon week-end à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]